okay let's start
and
my name is Michael Stipe
I'm a graphical technical steering
committee member and I'm also the author
of the hot chocolate graphql library.net
today I want to talk about building
modern applications with graphql and we
will use the newest bits of graphql so
the things that will come out with the
next spec release
and also the newest bits that we have
for net 7.
so before we get started let's make a
quick quiz to see how everybody is on
graphql
so take your smartphones and
join me
awesome
so first thing
have you used graphql before have you
used it in production or you just
experimented with it or you have no idea
and you just came to look what graphql
is
okay that's a very typical graph for
dotnet
so in.net we are a bit more conservative
that's why a lot of people are more I
heard about it but I have actually not
the right idea about it
and maybe I experimented with it but
like there's a lot of people who don't
run graphql in their day-to-day business
so how old do you think is graphql
okay
so a lot of people think it's 10 years
and the other bucket is more about five
years
let's have a look
so actually in 2012 what the year when
Facebook
used graphql in production
so they started actually developing it
earlier but 2012 was when they merged it
into production and actually back then
they called it super graph for a lack of
a better name and they renamed it in
graphql which
was not their best name because many
people
think it's a graph database query
language
so
yeah almost I have to update my slides
actually
okay so what is graphql
and to answer that we have to actually
look at why is graphed why did Facebook
create graphql
and it has all to do with mobile
applications
so there is the general assumption that
graphql is a JavaScript thing because it
is so popular in the graphical in the
JavaScript ecosystem
but actually it was developed for Native
mobile applications back then Facebook
had a big problem with their mobile
applications because people were
complaining about that their devices get
really hot they have slow startup times
the battery draining a lot and Facebook
really had pressure back then people
thought that Facebook cannot do the
drift to mobile applications
and there was talk about Facebook not
surviving that age as we now know
they're survived it
by the way
this was actually a Facebook app
much uglier than the new one and this
was the news feed back then
so the main issue that the Facebook
Engineers discovered when they looked
into the problem of their mobile
application was actually that they used
rest as a back-end test technology so
to say that it's wrong to use rest is
actually also wrong
um it was more they used what they used
in their normal website for Facebook so
they were using HTML to render their uis
in the mobile application so they
essentially built a wrapper and they
used rest to communicate with the back
end
but they used the rest API for their
desktop application
so when they opened the application
basically the first call was to fetch
the user
and they got data for that they actually
needed three properties but this request
returned 50.
and it was not just one call it was
actually a couple of calls and they
first fetched the current user then they
fetched the news story for that user
again they just needed a couple stories
because they didn't have even so much
screen space but they again got more
than 60 properties in that request
but the new story is not enough because
you also have comments so you would
collect all these IDs that you had from
the previous request and feed them into
another request to get the comments
and again you just need a couple of
properties there and you would collect
again a couple of IDs here and then
maybe fetch the profile picture of the
users that made comments
and this is not efficient it would look
something like this if you looked at the
developerative tools of chrome this is
faked but just to give you an idea we
call that a data waterfall where each
consecutive request is dependent on the
previous request so essentially we are
doing data aggregation on the client
side which is really really inefficient
so what I discovered is that their
mobile application actually has very
different needs from that
desktop application or their website
that was made for the desktop
at that time Facebook was not alone
actually there were a couple of
companies like Netflix who invested in
solution for this very problem because
they had applications running on game
consoles on mobile applications so on
desktop applications so they were trying
to solve that also in their way they
call that the Netflix client optimized
adapter which was
kind of what graphql was aiming at
there are also other patterns like the
BFF pattern but if you think about
Netflix if they really built a BFF for
each of their
applications that they deliver for for
the Xbox console for the mobile
applications they would have would be
very busy maintaining these
so this is where graphql came in and the
moment Facebook released it all these
companies that were doing experiments in
this space were actually rallying behind
graphql
so this is a graphql query it fetches
the currently sound in user and from
that user just the name if you send that
to our graphql server we actually get a
response that closely aligns to our
request it almost looks like we are
filling up our mtjs in graph here it's
not like that actually but it's a good
mental picture to start thinking about
graphql
but as our use cases change or we build
new experiences or new clients we can
just change our request ask for more or
less data from the back end and the
graphql server will fulfillment
but it when we look at this graph the
query here we can see it's not about
sparse Fields it's actually about trees
of data so that is why graphql is so
great with relations we can drill into
data for instance fetch in one go not
only the currently signed unusual but
also the news stories or the friends of
this user
there's one more Concept in graphql and
we call it a fragment and that is aimed
at the front-end Developers
so a fragment is our data contract for
our UI component you could say you can
bake that into your graphql query and
the great thing here is if we look for
instance add a react UI component here
we can see that we can co-locate our
data needs our data contract in our
react component the same works with a
blazer for instance we can do that in
the same way and then we have like you
know a component the data we need and
the data usage
and the second coolest thing is as I
compose my components I'm actually
composing my graphql request
so graphql gives clients or consumers of
our API the power to ask for exactly
what they want and nothing more and that
is giving you super fast back-ends and
super reactive front ends
so what is graphql
graphql is a query language for your API
and the runtime to fulfill these queries
so with raspberry we just have one
endpoint because we don't need all these
endpoints that we had with rest API
because we are defining a query and then
we send that to that endpoint and that
means we can fetch all the data we need
at a specific moment in time for our
user experience that we want to build in
one request
there's no overall under fetching on the
client
and when we looked at the request
earlier you saw these data aggregations
on the client side that is super
inefficient now we can aggregate the
data in the back end where we are close
to the database or close to our
microservices and we have zero latency
and graphql has built on a strong type
system and that is super important and
we will look at this aspects in a couple
of demos because these gives guarantees
to the client side you could say there's
something like this the open API
specification for instance but it's not
baked into a runtime we are just with
open the open API spec for rest we are
just saying okay this is my type system
on the back end but there's nothing in
four things is
so if you violate one of these types
there's nothing stopping this data
violations getting through the client so
the client always has to check with
graphql that's not the case and that
makes it super predictable to use
on top of this graph pearl is real time
before we look at some code so there are
three graphql operations that we know of
there's read operations this is our
graphql queries it's the get in rest
then we have write operations these are
our mutations
in graphql and see put post patch delete
in rest lastly we have in graphical
events and we call them subscriptions
okay
let's have a look at some code so this
is my first demo and we will dive into
how to build a small graphql server
let's get rid of this guy here
so how do we build a graphql server and
that is quite simple we just do a net
new web and that is an asp.net core web
application
and if we look at that web application
it's basically the minimal API we expect
right
okay
to make it graphical server we need to
add a package here and I'm adding here
the hot chocolate asp.net core package
and let's quickly restore it
and then we have all the ingredients to
build a graphql web server
so the first thing we talked about the
operation types and there is this query
operation type and that's the first
thing we want to build
so I'm gonna
create here a Class A simple class
called query and that's my root
operation type and the next thing let's
start with the hello world here so I'm
adding a little method here called hello
it has an argument name which has a
default word
and then we just concat here a string
and return the result
and that is a valid graph root type
next we're going to set up our graphql
server so I'm adding here a couple of
services
and in my service collection I'm adding
the graphql server here and then I'm
registering our query root type
awesome
so there's one thing left and that is
the transport so I need to map the
graphql transport here let's do that
so I'm just saying here map graphql and
then I'm done that is my graphql server
let's run it
actually let me do a
no hot reload because sometimes it
messes up
okay so this is my graph Fair server it
gives me a 404 because graphql by
default is on the graphql route
and if I open that up I'm greeted here
by our graphql IDE banana cake pop it's
also done by our project let me Zoom
that in
okay the coolest features actually that
we can take off the glasses but okay
now let's let's explore our graphql
server so this is basically a new tab
and I can explore my API with that I can
go here to the schema reference and you
can see now I have a query root type
here and my query root type Has a Field
hello which returns a non-allible string
in graphql we have no null ability and
you can see even my default value
translated into graphql
so that is awesome
we can now query that so let's write a
graphql query I'm querying here with my
field hello if I run that I get what I
expect but in graphql fields are more
like message so I can also pass in here
the name argument
we can say Michael run that and I get
hello Michael so that looks easy
so let's put a prop proper object
structure into that so let's create
maybe a simple book field here or a book
type
and a book has the author so let's also
create the author here and then let's
just create a simple method here to
fetch the authors
books
okay let's go back to my graphql server
let's refresh the schema
go into our schema reference and you can
see we have here the books field because
in graphql we don't have these verbs and
we apply these graphql best practices
and naming on top that's why it's called
books here
okay and I can also now query that
and as you see not only flat fields are
easy to integrate we actually inspect
the whole graph that or you hold object
tree that you expose to graphql and then
you can query for it
and we can run that and then we get the
data
okay
so that was the first
piece of graphql experience that we now
collected this is our query type that we
created we call this piece a resolver in
graphql because it resolves our data
and it translates to a graphical type
that looks like this the whole approach
here is called The annotation based
approach and that the original graph
graphql approach that Facebook started
with but their graph per server the
first graphql server was written in hack
it's compiled PHP
this C sharp type then translates into
this sdl type
and
it also infers correct all the pieces
here so our method our resolver becomes
a hello field and we also infer this
argument I saw our parameter from our
c-sharp message translates into an
argument of our field
we have in graphical different values we
can even have more complexity forward
valuation in net we can have full object
structures here
and we also understand non-nulliability
and null ability by default a graphql
type is nullable and the exclamation
mark makes it none of it so it's
reversed to see Sharp where we have the
question mark to make something nullable
in graphql we need to make something
non-nullable
okay so graphql lets us model
an interface to our core domain or we
could say graphql allows us to expose
our business layer in a much richer way
because the graphql type system has all
these capabilities like interfaces
discriminate unions and so much more so
I can model my business application then
infer from that the graphql schema and
then can access this over the wire
suddenly and ask for the data I need for
my application
so let's talk about transport here so
graphql is actually transport agnostic
but there is a graphical over HTTP spec
so we can communicate communicate with
graphql via HTTP or post HTTP get or
also other things even grpc or if you
wanted to do TCP sockets
most used is HTTP post that is the most
used
graphql transport
and we use that for queries or mutation
but for subscription real-time we could
also use web sockets or server-side
events
so I this talk is called modern
applications let's have a look at the
Modern application
that
got it here
that is actually my modern application
it um this demo was cooler a couple of
months ago it's about cryptocurrencies
the prices are not real so
there's no reason to sell
um
so this is a typical application that
works for mobile and I call it modern
application because it really lifts you
can see all the data is being updated in
real time and look here for all this
data I've fetched here it's one
graphical request and no matter what I
do in this application maybe I'm going
here onto the Bitcoin it's just one
graph per request
and that makes it super efficient over
any
network technology so if you're mobile
or if you're on desktop it's super
efficient
and even if I'm now fetching here a bit
more or different graph like the weekly
graph aggregation it's just one request
and actually graphql clients work
together with client-side caching that
means if I go back there's no graphql
request
and we are not fetching all the data we
are just always fetching the difference
that we need more
right
okay so let's build
or see how we can build for that the
back end
so what do we want to reach with graphql
we want to have a faster iteration
between front-end and backend because we
want to enable the front-end developers
to not have to go to our back-end
engineer every time to get a specific
optimized graphql or rest request we
actually want to give them a tool to
tell us what they need for their
components without without us back-end
Engineers needing to redeploy always our
backend
we want to have static typing and always
the most efficient way to fetch the data
on top of that our application should be
reactive like you saw
so let's have a look at how we could
build the backend for the application I
showed you
and that is demo2
so I'm using Entity framework now for my
demo here but you can also use other
Technologies like mongodb Raven the B
elastic or whatever it plugs just into
hot chocolate
so in this instance I have here the data
that's my asset my cryptocurrencies and
I also have an object price here right
and I want to make that fetchable
through graphql
so we already learned that we need a
query root type to fetch data so I have
here our query view type that we had
before with the hello world field
so in order to fetch my assets I'm going
to introduce a new
resolver here called get assets and this
resolver gets injected here the asset
context so we have
resolver level dependency injection and
we do that because this way the
execution engine knows what you your
resolver needs as dependencies and this
is super efficient in how we resolve
dependencies
the second thing is that I just do my
data fetching here and then I return a
variable
okay so my resolver is done
and I need to register now my DB context
here
with my graphql configuration
we do that with Entity framework to
essentially accommodate the non-thread
safety of the DB context so what we will
do here by default is inject a scoped
container into the resolver so you don't
have even when we parallelize data
fetching in the execution engine you
always have the right container instance
on which you can operate
okay with that we are actually ready for
running our application here
let me just do that.net watch how to
reload
and then let's
grab a new window
and go to our graphql endpoint
okay so I already have here my types is
my hello field and there is my asset
time and if I drill into it you can also
see it also has the nested structures
here so it inferred my whole DB context
here and we have everything in that we
need so I can just go here and actually
query my assets
let's get the names run that
and I get them
but it's a lot
so it's essentially all that I have in
my table and that's the right moment to
talk about pagination
so when Facebook
create a graphql they also restart
pagination
so they went away from the typical
offset paging because they had the
problem that there's always new news
stories coming into their table
and that means when you page through
their news stories you had the cases
that you got the same news story again
because you just skipped and took the
next data but there could be now a ton
of new
entities there
so they came up with something that is
called a cursor-based pagination or key
set pagination and the idea here is that
we navigate relatively from our entities
so we would not say skip take instead we
would say after this entity give me the
next five and this way our Pages move
actually
so let's see how we can Implement that
with hot chocolate
here into my demo
and then we need some code to get that
integrated so I'm going here to my query
type
and then I'm saying use paging and then
we're done
what's more about the concept
and we actually can now query the whole
thing so I'm refreshing here now you can
see my queries actually invalid because
we have Rewritten the types here we have
now an asset connection and you can see
we have a lot of arguments here like
first after last before and now
I would go here for the nodes field and
you can see that I'm only getting now a
couple here because we have a default
page size and to navigate that I can
grab the page in for now I can ask if
this has a next page and I also can ask
for the end cursor
and if I do that you can see here I have
the end cursor and that's the cursor of
this element here I can grab that
and just feed that here in I can say
after
this guy
I want the next two
okay and that translates automatically
because I returned here a variable into
my database query
let's go a bit further with that what if
I wanted to have client-side query
ability so to filter or to sort my data
set
so it works essentially the same way I
go here
I say
use projections maybe to only select
from the database what we actually ask
for then use filtering to filter what
items I want to have from my data set
and also use sorting
these are data middlewares and I need to
register them
so I'm going here and registers them so
now they are available everywhere in my
schema so I can use them
and let's refresh that here again
so the data structure is here the same
but you can see that I have now actually
more arguments here so I have a where
argument and an order argument
and now I could go in here and say I
want to order
my data set by the description which is
kind of stupid and that's why you
shouldn't just apply that on your data
set or on your business layer on your
repositories you actually should limit
that to what is useful in your
application
so
I'm going to do is
added that a bit
so we're going to introduce introduce
here another type and this type will
limit what we can sort for instance so
creating here a new input type and that
is an asset sorting input type here and
you can see I already added here the
bind Fields explicitly for my sort
type and then I can tell it what should
be sortable so in this case everything
that is navigatable from the price field
so all all the subfields that I can
reach here that should be sortable
there's one more issue at the moment I
have here the order by fixed so we could
only apply order structures on top of
that
so I'm going to rewrite my resolver here
a bit
and
now I'm checking if the user provided an
order here
then I'm not applying a default order
and with that
let's go back to our graphql ID refresh
that
and if we look at our schema here
I can see that I can only sort certain
things now
so on input
no that didn't work
sometimes hot reload messes up my demo
so
let's restart that
okay
so let's refresh that
and then write an order here
ah now we have the price
and only the price
and then we can actually sort that
in ascending order
price
so we want the Bitcoin we want Bitcoin
first so we are ordering by price in
descending order
I'm running that
and
actually let me get rid of the paging
here
of course that is something we don't
want
and then the Bitcoin should be first but
we could also have it in ascending order
and then I have something else there
and just to have a look at how this
translates you can see it perfectly
translates into the SQL we want you have
only the data I selected its name here
and we have here join with the asset
price field so it really nicely
translated into SQL
okay let's go back to the slides
and talk a bit about field middleware so
how does it work actually
so this guy is a resolver and on top
here the the use paging is actually a
middleware
and these other things are also
middlewares
and who knows the middleware pattern in
asp.net core
okay it's the same thing but we apply it
per resolver so we built up a field
pipeline here
and that means we have this pattern of
next weight so we can in each middleware
um essentially defer to the next one in
the pipeline and wait for the data to
return and then we can apply on top of
the query bus like expression trees and
these expression trees can then be
Rewritten by the database provider into
like the database
a query Lynch and that works not only
with paging it works also with filtering
and sorting and what have you whatever
you have so a graphical query like this
could be translated into the perfect SQL
version of that
but actually that's not the best
practice to just put your database under
there and it can be cool if you want to
do rapid development but typically we
don't have that Facebook actually
started with this and that says Ashley
where you should aim your work and
having graphql on top of your business
layer and then you create a nice domain
for your front end developers to fetch
data from so but when face when Facebook
released graphql people went more into
that direction they thought oh graphqra
it's a great Gateway technology so let's
not only have it for the data that I put
in my graph first server let's actually
merge data from everywhere in our
company in and it
turned into something like this where
maybe have something like the data
fetching I just wrote but I also have
other things where I can maybe have
aggregations in some Azure functions or
whatever and then I would merge that
into one type system
so what we're going to do for our
application is integrate this price
change service that we have running on
Azure and Azure had an outage today so
let's see if that demo works
so we have Azure Azure function
somewhere that lets us fetch for each
asset an aggregated price change
this price change service gives us a
response like that where we get the
aggregate percentage change and we want
to integrate that into our graph
but it not only works with rest whatever
you have there
okay so let's go to the next demo
three
so the first thing is because rest is
this thing that we don't have and I want
to even generate types for it so I can
just type it statically here and create
a schema.graphql this by the way is the
same server the service that we had
before a bit more advanced we have no
assets we also have users and stuff like
that in here and we want to kind of
merge now this rest service into our
graphql server so I'm creating here a
schema.graphware and what I can do is
type the data
set the static typing for my graphql
server
so I'm creating since this sdl type here
and say okay from the data that
restaurant has had I actually just want
the percentage change and that comes
from an Json object that I will have in
my execution engine
okay so this guy we need a to register
that's our graphql configuration you can
see it has grown a bit and we're gonna
add here the document that we just
created and then this type is now
already part of our type system so now
we need to wire that up so we kind of
need to create a function in our price
change object that we have or our price
object that we have
and but I don't want to change actually
my business layer or my data layer here
so in in hot chocolate we have kind of
these extension types so I can create a
class here and this extends our actual
model with all the graphql specific
stuff so I don't have to bleed graphql
specifics into my domain layer or into
my data layer
and in this instance I'm just adding
here method
it's called get change and it refers to
the type in my document so I'm saying
here it's a get change it's a Json that
I'm fetching with the HTTP client so
very raw
and then I actually can use it
start it
okay
let's refresh that it should not be
oh that's the wrong one
this one is better
let's refresh the schema here so it
still works same schema but now I can do
more I can drill into my price and
actually in my price I have here a
method or a field a graph here field and
that is the function that we just added
so when I fetch here the price
percentage I'm actually fetching from a
rest service here
okay let's fetch the hourly aggregation
and we do that and actually that is
quite slow
you can see and I can tell you why
because we are now fetching for each
item one
rest call and that is very inefficient
and Facebook also ran into these things
so they came up with a concept they call
data loader
so what does the data loader do when we
fetch this change field we are doing a
rest request here and we're doing a rest
request 10 times now and that is super
inefficient
so they came up with something that they
originally called preparable
um but nowadays it's called Data loader
and it allows us to batch request data
so how that works in a way that it's
transparent to everything that we do is
that the graphql resolver where instead
of doing the request itself ask data
loader and the data loader has a task
cache and each time you ask a data
loader it will actually look into the
task cache do I have for this key for
what you ask actually is a task to wait
on if not it will just issue a new task
and you can await that task
and that will actually lead to your
execution engine at some point to that
lock and that means your execution
engine cannot do anything anymore
because it's just awaiting everything
and at that point the execution engine
will
dispatch the data fetching calls to this
backend and get all the data in one call
but your rest service must be better for
that so my rest service allows me to
send multiple things in and if you have
Legacy infrastructure it's actually easy
to
to make it batchable so that is
where data loader come in it also
ensures consistency in your graph if you
fetch multiple times the same thing in
your graph it's actually always the same
version because we have a request cache
so in the request we are caching
everything that you resolve but as soon
as the request is done we clear the
cache for that request
okay let's actually build that in
quickly
so how do we rewrite that so to
introduce a data loader here let me do
that I'm creating actually just another
method and I'm essentially copied this
code down here and made it batchable so
I'm so I'm saying here I'm accepting
multiple symbols here
and I'm giving you back a map that tells
you this key has this item
um and then I'm doing here a bit the
data call aggregating the data and now I
can use it so this is just a method what
we do in hot chocolate is actually using
a source generator to generate you the
actual data loader so let's first update
this piece of code that is my resolver
um and let me get the new one and you
can see the resoma actually became a lot
easier because we just Corner this data
loader here and you can see from this
method we actually generated you the
more complex data loader code
so and then you can just ask here for
whatever data item you want to have
just run that and have a look at that
and suddenly our data fetching is a lot
more efficient you can see it's done
here and I'm fetching here all the items
in one go you can see there
okay so this is how we made integrating
external Services efficient and it feels
just like graphql nobody knows that
there are tons of micro Services behind
your graphql layer
okay let's talk about mutations so far
we just did querying data but how about
changing data because that is where
graphql really shines for the front-end
developer so this is a graphql query we
are fetching data here and the
components of that is actually the blue
thing the keyword query is the operation
that we're going to use to execute the
request on then we have the operation
name that is how we name it it's up to
us to name it and then we can pass in
variables into our query arguments it
kind of looks like a function so in
graphql we are actually creating
functions for your client then it's a
graphical operation so the next thing
here is these guys we call selection
sets and this essentially each selection
set we can select data and in a query we
have this root selection field here that
is our entry point and this is a query
and in a graphql query everything is a
query but when we think about mutations
only the top level field is a mutation
everything beneath this top level field
is actually querying the change that you
did to your system
and that allows me for instance to
create a new ice a new thing and then
select the impact that this had to your
back end
um mutations on the top level are
sequentially so the way we execute that
is first we would execute the first
notation then we would execute in
parallel or the subfields then the Next
Mutation again query the subfields and
ideally in this case where we add and
remove the thing nothing would have
happened at the end of this thing
okay let's have a look at how we can
Implement that and then I show you a
couple of cool things really with that
this demo
okay
it's just uh
watch that already
okay
so what we want to do here
is actually add a mutation and I already
have here in my types created in the
account an empty watch list mutation
class and what we want to add what we
want to add here is a mutation that
allows us to create a watch list entry
so essentially put one of the Bitcoins
or whatever into our watch list I
already have here a repository so far we
just used empty framework directly but
in this case I'm using here the watch
list repository which has a method here
add asset to watch list
and what I already did here in the
program CS
I registered my service
as something for graphql so graph wheel
knows I don't have to annotate that in
my functions I can just use the watch
list repository and it also knows how to
deal with it since this watch this
repository hasn't an asset context so
something of Entity framework in it we
scope it per resolver so again we create
an instance run the resolver and then
dispose it essentially
okay
so let's go into our mutation in our
watch list mutation class here and at
our mutation
sorry
and this mutation essentially is quite
clean we add the symbol here the symbol
is what we want to add to our watch list
we have the username from our state so
that's the sign in user and also we have
here the repository and we can execute
on that this is a valid mutation I can
just run it
let's just save it go to our client
see if I already
wrote something here up
yeah so this is how a mutation structure
could look like I'm adding here
something to my watch list Let me
refresh it refresh that and if I run
that I actually get an error because my
mutation
has some preconditions
in here
for instance
it throws if there's no user assigned in
it throws a not authenticated exception
and it also throws an exception if it
doesn't know the asset that I'm trying
to add here so these are actually cool
errors that I could have in my UI if I
could understand them
so what we can do in our mutation is
telling it what kind of errors are
actually relevant to my UI developer so
I'm adding here the exceptions that are
relevant to my user
and suddenly
I can refresh this thing
I could have a look at my mutations here
and then I can see okay it has errors
but it only not only tells me what
errors that it has errors but also what
errors this method or this mutation can
do and then I can actually write awesome
graphql queries where say okay I wanna
actually select the errors here
if this is an unknown asset error I want
to know what the invalid symbols are
that I provided
or if it's the wrong user then don't
tell me what user I should use just say
it's an error but
maybe I wanted to have a code here
that tells me what kind of error it was
in any case so I can run that here and
in this instance I'm not authenticated
so let's quickly sign in
and in my bank and any anything works
can say whatever
and actually let's do the second error
here and I can refresh that
and then this case I don't get what I
want actually
okay my demo crashed I didn't try that
out
it
okay there's something wrong with my DB
setup okay let's move on because I have
more
but actually it would have select if it
worked with the database there it would
have selected that it's worth the wrong
asset here which have shown you that the
symbol btc2 is actually wrong okay let's
move on because I have more to show
let's have a look at real-time data and
that is actually where grapher really
also shines and gives you all this
interactivity this reactivity in your
uis
so subscriptions is not about a similar
a single request response it's about
streams it's about streams of events
and also about
each event or when we call when we talk
about an event stream will cause
actually an execution of our graphql
execution engine and then these events
are actually translated into response
data
sounds complex but let me show you how
to build the simplest
subscription you can do
let's get rid of that guy
five
let's go
okay so again this is our service the
same service I just a couple of
iterations further
and we're gonna add now real-timeness to
it
so what I have here
is again the types
and let me first create a subscription
that is a bit artificial just to see how
it works so we can have a simple ping
pong here
so I'm gonna add here a little mutation
that triggers something
let's call it fumotation
and add to it a little method called
just send message
and what we do here is essentially we
can invoke that provide a message and
then we have a pub sub abstraction in
hot chocolate called itopic Event Center
and we support actually a ton of Pub
Subs like you can have rabbitmq or nuts
or redis or what have you behind that
abstraction and it's just a nougat
package that you have to add and then it
works like in this instance I added here
an in-memory pops up so not for
production but for our demo
okay let me go back
okay so I'm sending now here events this
message to a topic called message into
my event system and on the subscription
side
I can now introduce an unreceived
message and that is the the thing that I
could subscribe to from the client side
I told you my subscription resolver that
it's subscribed to the topic event
stream and I get here the event message
and then I'm in this case I just return
it
let's just run that well it's already
should already run
and let me go up here
so we can now write here the mutation
and in this case let's refresh my schema
and says
come on no that's wrong
shouldn't be wrong
is it wrong
again
refresh
okay
let me quickly fix that
[Music]
um
let's see
program
hyper Services because at the moment I
cannot see what I'm doing because we are
having a lot of events in my back end
here so what I'm going to do is to
switch off this event processor here
and then we can just watch that again
and
refresh
that seems all right
yeah and available schema but it should
actually tell me why
okay so this would work let's but I have
a hosted version to show you just how
this would work so this actually
everything I have to do let me show you
one more thing here and then I show you
the the thing I have as a backup
I'm getting rid of that it's always a
real time a demo that I mess up but okay
so the fact is the second thing here is
and let me go to my slide quickly this
is the spec components that we have in a
subscription so we have an event stream
in the response stream in our
application we have these price updates
so I'm not sending in the mutation
actually I want to subscribe to a real
live back end somehow right so we have
two components here actually
and that is the on receive uh no not the
on receiversity on price change resolver
that I have this guy here and it will
get a trigger for symbols that have a
price update and then use the data
loader here to load that price update
and then there is a second component and
that's our event stream so I can create
here an event stream and an event stream
for us it's just an is enumerable that
yields events back and I can actually
tell my subscription here
to subscribe with
this stream so I'll use this stream
method whenever I use a subscribe to
create a stream and then listen to it
and behind that stream could be anything
that you have in your infrastructure you
don't even have to use our
abstraction here
let's just quickly see if that works
otherwise I use the thing I have
prepared
try
so would be cooler
create new document
oh yeah okay so some something in my
client state was messed up
seems to be so it works so I'm doing
here a subscription
and in this case I'm using the on price
change event here
and I'm subscribing here to the symbol
and then to the latest price that we get
and
and now I have to change one more thing
here because I disabled our real-time
events
go in here
fix that
let's hope it
okay it comes up you can see all the
events actually happening here and we
subscribe to it and you can see real
time my query coming in and the coolest
thing here is from a client perspective
the user that uses your graph per
endpoint it's just a change of keyword
and
this also this is at a moment running
over sockets but I also could say
because we Implement a lot of these
Graphics I also could say I wanted over
essentially in HTTP post call
and then it works the same you can see
new stuff coming in
okay
so there is one more thing
and let me go for that this guy here
let's refresh that
go away
go back to slides
oh
I cannot skip the animation so we have
to Wade through it
okay
so there's one more aspect and that is a
feature we are in the spec working group
are having the most focus at the moment
on it's called deferent stream and this
feature allows the consumer of the API
to Mark sections of the graph that we
want to defer or de-prioritize let's say
for instance the rest data that we get
from rest is actually slow it is slow
so this piece of query we know is slow
how can we deal with that
so with different stream we suddenly
have a tool
to say this section deferred I need the
name immediately and then sent me the
rest whenever you're you're finished
we can do that with defer or we can also
stream lists
and what we are doing in the execution
engine is essentially breaking up the
request graph into two waitables
promises we first focus on the initial
payloads and then sent you the
subsequent payloads
let me show you how that actually works
and
the use case for instance if you if you
are here on the main page then it's all
the data that we fetch here in one go
but look at this I can scroll to the
side there are more graphs
when I initially open this page the user
doesn't see this
and the moment he sees the content and
swipes to the side it will already be
there but it doesn't have to be there
from from the first millisecond on so
what we can do
is
change our request here this my request
at the moment takes around a second
you can see or two seconds on this Wi-Fi
but now I can optimize I could say
actually stream this I need the first
item immediately
and also this section I know it's quite
expensive so defer that
and then run that and you can see 210
milliseconds for the First Data to
arrive so I can render my page with all
the data I need and what is happening
here is that we are patching data so I
get the Bitcoin price here first and
it's actually 10 patches and then at
some point I get graph data here and my
client patches that and it it looks as
if the site is super speedy and uh it's
super fast actually it still takes two
seconds for all the data to arrive but
we now spreaded it out and can already
render
um
okay
let me get you then so there was uh a
nice bachelor project at the I cannot
even read it but at the University in
Sweden that looked at the speed of
graphql and rest and the graph
implementation as a whole in the.net
ecosystem they found out okay I spare
you the abstract that hot chocolate is
not only the fastest graphql server in
the.net ecosystem
but it's also faster than a rest API so
how can that be
because with graphql when you specify
your graphical request you create the
most optimized graph to uh the most
optimized rest service ever because you
saw when I showed you the structure
actually graphql request is like a
method so you create like stored
procedures for for a rest service you
could say and at the end when you deploy
your graph per server you have the most
optimized rest communication because
it's just everything HTTP post even
the stream streaming data it's just
simple HTTP post request that works over
HTTP 1.1 so you get the most optimized
API ever that's why we can compete with
all the other platforms
the second thing here so this is
actually this work was done on hot
chocolate 12. it took 81 lines of code
to X to create the example 79 lines of
code with the minimal API with hot
chocolate 13 the new version you need
actually four nines less now so we the
code that you have to write is even less
than with a minimal API now
so conclusion
so graphql is evolving rapidly there are
new features like different stream there
are other things coming out and it gives
you all the tools to finally get rid of
this this endless Cycles between front
and end back-end Engineers so you can
suddenly move on both on both sides
without stopping the other
um and graphql is like if you look at
other platforms Java JavaScript or
it's rapidly evolving and has rapid
adoption Microsoft will show I think it
built a lot of graphql products so
there's a lot coming also now from the
Microsoft side
and if you look like tools like team
Source or they are running on graphql
GitHub is running on graphql Netflix New
York Times Airbnb all graphql even
Twitter is running on graphql so if you
look at the biggest companies they are
all running on this technology today
um LinkedIn is by the way also running
on graphql
okay with this all I showed you is open
source it's free so you can get to our
GitHub representation repository Focus
Fork it play it and play with it
um connect with us and
start us if you want
and for that I'm done if anybody has
questions I'm open to that
[Applause]
uh same as was rest
it's it's HTTP post so it's the same
Authentication
authorization depends but it's the same
that you do with rest you have to other
you have the new application layer
or you annotate it we have the same
annotations that you would do in rest
you can just put them on the graph where
specific stuff and then we also use the
same policy engine by default but we
also support Opa the open policy agent
so if you want to use a different policy
system you can also plug it in
application Factor
do we have any
yes
so we have like a testing framework we
also have like a client that's called
strawberryshake4.net
and like if you're if if you're looking
for the JavaScript ecosystem that tons
of clients but yeah we also have a
client called strawberry shake and there
you write these fragments or write these
queries and we compile you the client to
that